[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
l'alternativa l'alternativa deriva dal
latino alter che vuol dire altro se lo
guardiamo sulla treccani l'alternativa
el'alternarsi ripetersi a turno i due
cose oppure possibilità necessità di
scelta fra due soluzioni
e qualcosa che abbiamo visto tante volte
in matrix neo aveva la possibilità di
scegliere tra la pillola rossa e la
pillola blu oppure le persone della mia
generazione hanno sognato di poter
essere al posto di harry potter e
scegliere la casata di hogwarts oppure
quando avevamo messo il primo gioco
dentro il gameboy abbiamo l'obbligo di
dover scegliere terra fuoco o acqua
scoperto a cui passavano charm under
non so se vi ricordate oppure al cinema
una delle cose che ci hanno insegnato a
guardare
è l'eterna lotta tra il super il super
il superuomo batman colui che si è
costruito da solo e ha costruito
tecnologia per supportarsi è la persona
che veniva dal da un altro pianeta il
supereroe superman
oppure semplicemente quando siamo a casa
e cerchiamo cosa mangiare troviamo il
frigo vuoto quando abbiamo già scritto e
ci troviamo davanti un enorme un enorme
lista di ristoranti o quando di 1 su
skyscanner e troviamo quattro
cinquecento possibilità di connessione
tra una città e un altra o booking per
dirti milano mirano a 1.667 properties
booking o ancora più semplice quando
siamo sul netflix e ci troviamo davanti
almeno 24 film solo nella prima
schermata o spotify dove nel primo a
home page ci troviamo più
canzoni di quelle che possiamo vedere in
una sola giornata ascoltare una sola
giornata e quindi facciamo la
comparazione tra spotify e netflix che
dovremmo conoscere tutti quanti ci sono
6 mila titoli tra film e serie tv su
netflix e 50 mila canzoni 50 milioni di
canzoni
una delle cose che mi piace mi piace
parlare è il quanto tempo ci vuole per
guardarle tutto ascoltarle tutte e
parliamo di più di sei anni sulla parte
in fx e più di 280 5 per la parte
spotify
viviamo in un mondo fatto di scelte dove
la scelta è continua e quando avevo
quattro anni
una delle cose probabilmente che veniva
chiesta e vedere chiesto a tutti i
piccoli bambini
ecco se vuoi loro natale e le prime
scelte abbia voluto fare o la seconda
cosa vuoi fare da grande e questa scelta
ci colpisce ci colpirà per tutta la
nostra vita
io ancora non ho capito cosa voglio fare
e allora perché parliamo della follia
dell'alternativa
vi spiego che è un paradosso
l'alternativa in sé per sé più ne hai
più alternative ai e meno sei contento
almeno sei felice ma facciamo un passo
indietro perché è una cosa del genere
proviamo a spiegarvelo se massimizza le
alternative se ne avessimo infinite
avremo sicuramente più scelte saremo
probabilmente molto più liberi e
probabilmente tutto crescerebbe
immaginiamoci poter scegliere senza
vincoli e quindi invece di scegliere la
macchina che costa y non possiamo
comprare la macchina tipo ferrari o
qualcosa del genere senza dover pensare
quello che guadagniamo e quindi
prendiamo un caso invece un po più
vicino a noi la ferrari non tutti ci
possiamo permettere ma andiamo al
supermercato troviamo questa immagine
questa è un supermercato medio che ho
fotografato qualche qualche giorno fa a
milano e vediamo una un'intera facciata
di pasta e probabilmente ci pensiamo
andiamo a prendere quella che conosciamo
quella che ci piace o quando c'è
l'offerta proviamo qualcosa di nuovo ma
la cosa che dobbiamo pensare e chi in
quel momento
ci siamo trovati davanti cento
possibilità di scelte o addirittura
nella nello scaffale a fianco c'erano
150 tipi di salsa di concentrati l'altro
caso il mcdonald's dove el antonomasia
del fast food del cibo veloce ci sono
più di cento combinazioni possibili
e ogni anno l'azienda ne provo tanta in
più per farci spendere qualcosa in più
per farci fare un'esperienza ancora più
bella e quindi quanti di noi o quanti di
voi hanno hanno difficoltà a scegliere
ma soprattutto abbiamo tutti un telefono
giusto e quante up abbiamo che
fondamentalmente non utilizziamo pensate
che si stima che più del 60 per cento
delle app che abbiamo in tasca non
vengono mai aperte e quindi quanto di
voi non hanno uno smartphone
probabilmente in questa domanda nessuno
alzerà la mano e se c'è qualcuno
veramente voglio stringermi la mano
perché vivere una vita del genere è
sicuramente migliore di quella che
vediamo tutti noi siamo 24 ore al giorno
sette su sette a lavorare natale
capodanno e ferragosto inclusi la vera
domanda non è più quando si lavora ma la
domanda che ci troviamo a dover
rispondere
e quando non si lavora
questi due numeri il primo quello sulla
vostra sinistra è il numero di volte che
io apro il cellulare al giorno è quello
di destra è il numero di notifiche che
ricevo ripeto al giorno e allora troppe
alternative possono i generano paralisi
immaginatevi trovare una scena del
genere dove potrete nella 1 2 3 4 10 20
possibilità di scelte che cosa fate se
sbagliate la scelta o cavolo potevo
andare in quell'altra e invece nel caso
in cui ne avete solo inviate solo due
senza sinistro a destra che cosa
succederebbe e quindi nel caso del sulla
vostra sinistra quello delle tante
alternative si genera paralisi
nel caso invece di destra se ce ne sono
poche si genera entropia
difficoltà andare avanti difficoltà di
prendere una decisione di far crescere
il sistema e quindi probabilmente più
fede più alternative meno felicità meno
alternative più rimpianti sembra
perfetto no sembra un'equazione
matematica gran peccato è totalmente
folle e totalmente folle lo possiamo
vedere in vari colori senza alcun
problema ma la realtà in sé per sé e che
esiste un costo e che ovviamente quello
che abbiamo dovuto scegliere ci è
costato qualcosa e quindi capiamo come
fare
qual è il vero costo è l'alternativa la
nostra soddisfazione ovviamente in
positivo a cui dobbiamo sottrarre i
rimpianti anticipati di quello che non
abbiamo scelto avremmo potuto fare
medicina nella nostra vita
o ancora meglio il senso di colpa
caspita potevo prendere quella persona e
non l'ho presa o potevo fare questo
attività questo lavoro e non l'ho fatto
ho il costo delle opportunità caspita mi
è costata messo data quella laurea nelle
donne come in economia ma allora qual è
il segreto della felicità
e qual è la formula ho provato a
metterla su due assi 1 sull'asse
l'alternativa e l'altro sull'asse dà
soddisfazione e probabilmente misterix
si trova in una situazione dove più ci
sono alternative più soddisfazione
la verità è che è un equilibrio e questo
equilibrio dipende un pochettino da chi
siamo e andrea catherine avranno due
equazioni diverse e ci sarà un
equilibrio personale anche ognuno di noi
deve raggiungere ma su cosa sul lavoro
sulla vita privata sugli altri sugli
effetti sugli amicizie sul futuro su
quello che vogliamo fare da qui a 10
anni scegliere e coraggio e
responsabilità ogni scelta la portiamo
dietro didietro con noi ogni scelta e
capacità scegliere grande capacità di
poter prendere quella decisione e vivere
con quella scegliere molto difficile ma
soprattutto scegliere è un grande lusso
immaginiamoci non aver avuto la
possibilità di scegliere come tante
persone sulla faccia della terra
scegliere una grande grande grande
opportunità
ma soprattutto che cosa succederebbe
e cosa succede nella società quando noi
prendiamo una scelta cosa succede quando
scegliamo di fare una professione che
nel futuro tra che era tanto o
semplicemente che cosa succede nel
mercato il lavoro quando nei prossimi
cinque anni 200 mila medici mancheranno
dovremmo prenderli importanti dagli
altri paesi perché siamo stati troppo
stretti a fare il test ingresso
probabilmente perché il quota 100 li ha
portati tanti fuori e allora cosa
succede nella sanità e cosa succede nel
momento in cui mancheranno i medici o
semplicemente nella scuola dove sotto
paghiamo i professori che stanno creando
il futuro dei nostri figli e delle
persone che che verranno e nella propria
città
quando scegliamo di lanciare quella
cartina per terra invece di mettere nel
cestino
qual è il vero effetto che da le scelte
sono diventati il mio business sono
diventate il mio mestiere soprattutto le
decisioni strategiche che sono quelle
che chiamiamo il mio prodotto è quello
che faccio e aiutare aziende a prendere
decisioni strategiche su cosa sul mondo
dell'online sul mondo del digital su
tutti questi mondi dove l'innovazione ha
portato un grande gap tra la generazione
che c'è la generazione che verrà e poi
nella mia start up con il mio socio
nicola ci siamo inventati di fare il
mondo dei ristoranti e quindi abbiamo
fatto la prima golf kitchen d'italia che
cos'è una cucina fantasma che sembra più
né posto ma quello che facciamo e
cercare di prendere le scelte dei
clienti che aprono le app di delivery
creando di brand virtuali dove possono
scegliere i loro prodotti
e allora torniamo alla prima slide ve la
ricordate alternativa e come licenza
poetica mi prendo di chiamarlo
alternativo quindi di prendere il
sostantivo maschile quindi si
posizionano quella o nel basso poi
prendo la lati posiziono la r
poi line al centro e poi lati e poi la e
le abbiamo avuto davanti per tutta la
giornata e nessuno ancora ha detto che
probabilmente questo evento e ramen tubi
doveva succedere a taranto
e taranto alternative tante ma fatemi
fare un'altra un altro passaggio e così
chiudo se quelli che vediamo lì
diventasse una e la posizion assimo alla
fine della parola che vado a comporre
prendessimo le ultime tre lettere che
mancano nella composizione
fondamentalmente vedremo che in taranto
e l'ilva hanno tante alternative
siate le alternative situ l'alternativa
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]